un paso más para acabar con la ya
conocida como guerra eterna el
comandante de más alto rango de eeuu en
afganistán el general de scott miller
entregó el mando en kabul tras tres años
en el cargo y lo hizo con un mensaje de
concordia
es importante que las partes militares
establezcan las condiciones para una
solución política y pacífica en
afganistán
le releva en el cargo frank mckenzie
jefe del comando central de eeuu quien
operará desde tampa florida el 31 de
agosto se espera la salida definitiva de
las tropas estadounidenses sin embargo
el nuevo comandante todavía tendrá que
proteger la diplomacia estadounidense el
aeropuerto de kabul apoyará la defensa
del gobierno de afganistán y continuará
con la lucha antiterrorista
esta ceremonia marca un hito importante
en la transición de nuestra
participación en afganistán esperan el
mando central de eeuu dijo que ya se han
retirado el 90% de las tropas un
abandono que ha aprovechado el talibán
que ya controla un tercio de los 421
distritos de afganistán la situación en
provincias como
es alarmante que como sabe el pueblo de
afganistán en los últimos tres meses
como resultado de la guerra más de
12.000 familias han tenido que salir
desplazadas muchas familias afganas han
escapado al vecino tayikistán rusia teme
que los últimos movimientos de eeuu y el
talibán puedan provocar el avance del
islamismo hacia asia central su patio
trasero y acusa a eeuu
las autoridades del pentágono quieren
disponer de sus tropas militares para
poder lanzar ataques contra afganistán
desde el exterior luque o instalando un
contexto que demuestra el fracaso de una
guerra que empezó tras los atentados del
11 de septiembre de 2001
joe biden asegura que eeuu cumplió su
misión con la muerte de osama bin laden
y el repliegue de al qaeda pero para
afganistán el panorama es incierto